[Music]
hello fellow hunters here's a guide to
getting the secret ending and alternate
boss the moon presents the first thing
we'll go over in order to get the secret
ending and alternate final boss is
acquiring the items needed to trigger
the event you will need to collect three
of the four umbilical cords in the game
we'll start with the first one which is
probably one of the easiest ones to get
first make sure you kill the Blood star
beast so that you can gain access to
this area next go to the cathedral ward
go to the right where the double doors
are and take this elevator up now kill
the old man in the wheelchair with a
Gatling gun run across the bridge like
area and hang a right at the platform
and drop down here now keep going until
you see a room full of planks get to
this plank and make the jump over to the
platform with the door open the doors
and you'll end up in the abandoned
workshop within the workshop you'll get
the doll outfit and on your way up to
where gurmann usually sits you'll get
your first of the umbilical cords the
next one comes from our friend in the
clinic however to ensure you actually
get the umbilical cord
kill rom the vacuous spider first next
you'll need to head over to the
forbidden woods here you'll have to
traverse until you get to a point where
the dogs are in cages once you find the
dogs you'll see an alternative path that
you can take into a cave go into the
cave and find the ladder here turns out
these two ladders brings you all the way
back to the beginning of the game next
go through this path and enter the back
of the claim
once inside you should see our good
friend keeled over on the medical table
turns out she might have something in
her stomach only way to find out is cut
it open right surprise surprise we found
our second umbilical cord
the third umbilical cord is easy to get
as it comes with story progression after
defeating Margo the wet nurse you'll
receive your third umbilical cord if you
happen to have gotten all three of these
you only need three to trigger the event
however there is a fourth one in case
you missed one of these the fourth is a
little trickier to get as it comes from
another npc named Ariana after defeating
vicar Amelia make your way to the
streets to the side of the cathedral
pass the flamethrower guy proceeded down
the street and head left toward a door
with a red lantern and talked to a young
lady talk to her a second time to tell
her it's safe to go to the cathedral
ward if you haven't triggered the
ability to send people to the cathedral
ward make sure to talk to Owen chapel
door will then give you the ability to
do so
now that you saved Ariana you can leave
her be for now after defeating her go to
wet-nurse
head back to the cathedral ward here
you'll notice ariana is no longer in her
chair and it seems that there's
bloodstains on the ground head back to
the basement which is through the study
and you'll see that ariana is sitting in
another chair but with what appears to
be some type of baby monstrosity next to
her kill the baby to get another
umbilical board now return back to the
hunter's dream which is probably now
burning if you've killed Murr go next
consume three of the umbilical cords
after doing so enter the area where
gurmann is and refuse to give your life
up after defeating Kerman you'll queue
the ending you normally see except this
time somehow you deflect away the
monster trying to eat you
now we enter the fight with a moon
presence the alternate ending boss from
what I could tell you could easily avoid
his melee attacks it also uses its tail
to whip around and attack you as well as
burrowing it into the ground to get to
you from rank one of the most dangerous
moves the moon presence has is its eye
beam it seems to hit in a frontal cone
and will reduce your life to 1 HP but it
doesn't appear to kill you after this
move though there's a lot of downtime
for you to get in and attack and gain
that light back here's your chance to do
big damage to the boss
so get aggressive it appears that the
head and the hands might be the weak
points because that's what triggers
stagger State for me continue to dodge
the melee attacks and when the eye beam
comes make sure they either heal up
first or just go in attack and get your
life back
rinse and repeat and it should die now
you've earned yourself a secret
alternate ending
are you cold
oh good hunter what are your thoughts on
the ending was this the best ending
leave your comments below and stay tuned
to gain spot.com for more blood-borne
coverage
[Music]
you